moi je suis entrepreneur dans la
rénovation intérieure d'accord ça se
passait bien pour toi avant ça fait
combien de temps que tu fais ça bah ça
fait ça va faire 20 sur 20 ans
d'accord et en 20 ans on va dire que là
depuis on va dire depuis le covid
aussi on a oublié celui-là il est
toujours là parce que je vous dis on
voit que même dans le bâtiment ça ça
commence à sentir mauvais on parle de
l'inflation des des restaurateurs de
l'énergie et tout mais nous dans le
bâtiment aussi on en parle pas trop mais
tout a doublé voire triplé
après qu'on nous dise que c'est
l'Ukraine c'est l'Ukraine il y a un
moment donné il faut arrêter de prendre
des gens pour des cons parce que sur
certains matériaux où on sait que c'est
pas fabriqué en Ukraine je pense que il
y a beaucoup de gens qui profitent de
cette situation
voilà et un moment donné il faut que ça
s'arrête c'est faut arrêter parce que là
c'est plus vivable et puis même dans le
bâtiment
changements de problèmes aussi avec les
l'Europe tout ça la concurrence les gens
ont tellement peur aujourd'hui de pas
travailler cassent les prix et ça et en
fait c'est tout est comme disait c'est
un cercle vicieux peu importe et puis
c'est qu'une question de temps là on
s'est les boulangers c'est mais tout le
monde c'est en fait à la suite c'est une
question de temps avant que ça touche
tout le monde exactement et c'est nous
ça touche dans le bâtiment ça va toucher
derrière c'est qu'une question de temps
ou même les gens de classe moyenne je le
vois moi j'ai des clients de classe
moyenne qui quittent de Paris bien sûr
pour aller en banlieue parce qu'ils ont
plus les moyens voilà donc c'est pour ça
que il y a un moment donné il faut
bouger il faut bouger il faut pas
trouver des solutions sur du court terme
là je t'écoutais dire ça va peut-être
aider sur le coup mais je pense qu'il
faut vraiment revoir après après ça
permet en fait de faire un fondement qui
va permettre peut-être de repartir
derrière parce qu'aujourd'hui mais je
pense que c'est du long terme il y a
beaucoup de choses qui soient la crise
du covid
l'inflation donc forcément le long terme
c'est ben moi je vois que je peux pas
embaucher parce que bien sûr on voit
qu'aujourd'hui les entreprises parce que
moins de charge bon on écrase tout le
temps les petites on voit les nouilles
nous ils nous font pas de cadeaux
l'alcovie de nous on a eu un report de
charge mais bien sûr je sais savoir que
moi mes salariés j'ai payé des
cotisations et un moment un moment je
vais dire le report de charge tu sais
que tu vas le payer c'est juste un
report ce qu'il aurait fallu faire un
moment quand elle devine on a pris je
sais plus combien de milliards pour le
covid un moment tu dis cette année on
oublie aujourd'hui il faut aider les
entreprises qui ont des salariés et qui
font qui créent des emplois sinon tu es
mort parce que sinon si peut-être pas en
fait le le nerf de la guerre il est où
il faut aider en premier les entreprises
et c'est que les entreprises derrière
voir si les entreprises d'ailleurs elles
font le boulot et elles embauchent des
gens à des prix corrects et à des
salaires corrects mais si un moment
t'étrangle les entreprises tu sais que
derrière ça va être comme un ça tout va
s'écrouler et c'est comme c'est il y a
un savoir-faire artisanat qui bien sûr
mais aujourd'hui on est on peut pas être
compétitif parce qu'aujourd'hui on se
bat pas avec les mêmes armes que les
autres forcément on peut se bat pas avec
les mêmes armes que les autres pays qui
qui qui malheureusement produisent
beaucoup moins cher donc aujourd'hui
quoi qu'il arrive c'est un cercle
vicieux et à la fin tu sais que tu es
mort donc aujourd'hui si on est pas les
entreprises c'est le premier la première
chose à faire et derrière et ben voilà
derrière c'est sûr il faut qu'on soit
plus compétitif aujourd'hui on n'est pas
assez compétitif donc forcément on se
fait bouffer
c'est moi j'ai vu des devis des clients
m'ont sorti des devis c'est près du
matériel bah oui tu me dis est-ce que tu
mais je te dis tu peux tu ne te bats pas
avec les mêmes armes aujourd'hui donc
aujourd'hui tu es mort et quand moi
j'entends Manon aussi Manon aujourd'hui
parce que elle fait bien fait de
l'intérim et un moment et ben les mecs
quoi ils prennent des intérimaires non
mais je sais ma chérie parce que aussi
un moment ça va coûter moins cher et que
et que aujourd'hui j'aurais préféré que
Manon elle a un CDI et qu'elle me dit
j'ai pas voilà ben aujourd'hui le
problème c'est que pour les pour les
employeurs et pour les entreprises ça
coûte tellement cher que derrière c'est
Manon qui qui on paye les frais j'étais
comédienne en fait demain j'étais dans
l'industrie du cinéma et j'ai dû arrêter
tout ça j'ai dû arrêter mon rêve parce
que c'est ma passion de base et moi je
souhaitais être épanouie je dis et c'est
ça qu'on veut te faire un métier
malheureusement des fois on n'a pas
forcément le choix et moi j'avais le
choix avant tout ça j'avais le choix et
je souhaitais être comédienne je
souhaitais vraiment vivre de ça je
commençais à y arriver il y a le covid
effectivement ça m'a l'accumulation de
choses on a pratiquement tous permis
perdu pardon l'intermittence du
spectacle tout ça ça m'a cassé non pas
tout le monde n'a pas perdu parce qu'il
qu'il y en a qui il y en a qui a aussi
des gagnants du covid
dans chaque crise il y en a toujours
il y en a qui il y en a qui exactement
et il y en a qui se souviennent en tant
que ça coûte x 2 pas bien sûr non mais
c'est n'importe quoi c'est n'importe
quoi